go back to Facebook and assistant my
younger brother just messaged me to say
that I was actually on holiday when that
James Haskell story ran in the Daily
Mirror he remembered it so I'm off the
hook so I may have to withdraw my
apology to Mrs Haskell the mum uh but
actually I'll take responsibility
because I take accountability when
you're the boss you're the boss right so
I'll I'll take that on for the team
um well Prince Harry says he's a
feminist uh so in his own words here's
how he talks about women from his
mother-in-law to be disabled matron at
his school
you wrote I even wanted Camila to be
happy maybe she'd be less dangerous if
she was happy
how was she dangerous because of the
need for her to rehabilitate her image
that made her dangerous that made her
dangerous because of the connections
that she was forging within the British
press I want to sort of just briefly
talk about your stepmother and press
because you you were pretty consistently
scathing and suggest that you are
scathing
well scaling towards well as in you say
that your interests were sacrificed on
her PR altar I think in the book it's
very clear what happened there's no part
of any of the things that I've said are
scathing towards any member of my family
especially not my stepmother unlike the
other matrons Pat wasn't hot Pat was
called that was small walking was hard
stairs were torture she descend
backwards glacially
often we stand on the landing below her
doing antique dances making faces
do I need to say which boy did this with
the most enthusiasm we went on mocking
her as she came down the stairs the
reward was worth the risk
for me the reward wasn't tormenting poor
Pat but making my mates laugh who the
hell is this editor
loathsome toad I gathered
everyone who knew her was in full
agreement that she was an infected
posture on the ass of humanity plus
excuse for a journalist
now that is happens to be a good friend
of mine uh and yeah not a nice way to
speak about a woman right especially
someone who gets so uptight when people
use that kind of language about his wife
well joining me now is journalist and
friend of Camilla page another Wyatt the
science raw photographer friend of
everybody Arthur Edwards and the
journalist and historian Dr Tessa Dunlop
Arthur let me start with you because
you've covered the Royals for longer
than I've been alive sorry not quite
it's sort of jumped that one only 40
years
um you know them you've known them all
very very well what what do you make of
this this book and the interviews around
it well you know I'm pretty disgusted
the way they said about Camilla because
uh she is just the nicest person and you
know when she married the prince
he risked everything for that there was
a lot of hostility towards him over that
but you know what she just got aired
down and worked and worked and worked I
remember those early jobs with her she
was so nervous but she kept trying try
and try and then in the end people got
to love her because they found what a
really nice person she is
and Harry just trashing her like that I
was so I really wanted this smacking one
you know I thought it was an awful thing
to do if she's been nothing but nicer I
remember once when he you know I think
it was 2000 2017 and he made some stupid
mistakes a statement about it he didn't
want to be remember the whole family
anymore
and I remember talking to her about the
next day she said you know he's such a
lovely boy Camilla all she said was how
nice he was you know speaking I said
I've known Camila a long time she comes
from the next door Village to me I've
known her a long time in her family
they're incredibly nice people very down
to earth very normal I had lunch with
the uh this now Infamous lunch with
Jeremy Clarkson was out before Christmas
uh she was utterly delightful to
everyone and I don't think she deserves
this would be called a dangerous villain
by by Prince Harry as we head towards a
coronation where her and Charles are
gonna you know be crowned our king and
queen of this country I just felt was so
damaging and unnecessary Tessa defend it
I just would like as it's all about
truth and accuracy I'm not sure he
called her a dangerous villain a villain
and dangerous no he explained that she
was the villain of the peace because she
was The Other Woman slightly taken out
of context in fact that line it just
just yeah but he knows what he's right
he knows when he writes those things
that'll be the headline
you're crediting him with High um
intelligence and I think Harry
understood things I don't think it's
stupid
and we're seeing the full blast of it
right now what about the way he
generally talks about women just can we
just pick up on the Camilla thing and
what you two of both said that she's
Charming that you know she's the woman
next door literally for you the village
next door that she does have this very
natural way she's comfortable in her
skin she fits in she gets on with it she
loves the Gin she loves the [ __ ] we all
love Camilla do you know when that
replaces your dead mother and when you
feel like an outsider
just on bridge there yeah but sure
there's a feeling hang on but hang on
his mother died in 1997. we're now 2022.
he's nearly 40 years old all right
they're just there comes a title it's
2023. there comes a time when you just
have to not move on and forget your
mother but actually accept your father's
very happy with a woman be married for
17 years why would you try and ruin her
reputation in the run-up to the
coronation I think there's probably
aspects of jealousy where she has
managed to rehabilitate Her Image and
interestingly she's done that in Britain
she hasn't successfully done that in
other Realms or indeed within the
Commonwealth where things are on much it
hasn't been given a chance yes but it is
therefore his point stands it is about
her ability to work alongside the Press
of which both of you two are significant
players sure so that point stands now it
has his relationship with his stepmother
only they know the real truth don't they
and we're only hearing well we're never
gonna we're never going to hear
Camilla's side Camilla has other things
no no Camila will know that she will
never respond to any of this that's why
I feel sorry for all the rules because
they're trapped now with this hand
grenade going on the thing is that
Camilla had to endure
such vicious attacks from the press and
a level of violence from the public that
Megan
um yeah I mean I've never it was never
even close I remember when Camilla had
bread rolls
Roy was not true well she says it's not
true maybe it wasn't but there was she
really was at one point the most hated
woman in Britain and Diana who was much
clever with the press and was younger
and More Beautiful well Donna learn to
work with the meat I mean she used to
work with me
up but the point is that Camilla never
complained no she never skied I mean
I've known her since I was like she's
incapable it's going to be nice let me
ask you on a wider point about the way
that he talks about other women in this
book and in particular not just taking
down his sister-in-law which he does I
mean revealing text messages after his
wife Susan newspaper for revealing
contents of a letter from her father the
brass neck of Harry to then reveal text
messages without the consent of Kate in
his book to make money yes but what
struck me is the tordiness of the book
um the sexual aspects which you might
mounting older women behind the park you
might expect that from a reality TV even
the Kardashians you don't expect it from
the royal family and it is very sexy
this is very different and the stuff
about this poor matron Pat Jones she has
a name Pat Jones she was a matron at
Love Grove School he calls her greasy he
calls her ugly none of the boys got
horny when they saw her she had a spinal
deficiency which he mocked and did it in
person he mocked the way can you defend
any of that oh why does he have to talk
about todgers
take down his matron I want to make two
points one to answer your specific
question on the matron that is
Preparatory School mentality oh really
yeah I mean I think they should be
confined to the dust why would you put
it in a book guess what it's been
written why when you're supposed to be a
great feminist
we don't even know if she's alive or not
but with her family are brothers but
this was probably something she talked
about I I was a matrix says just hang on
it was written now